hey everyone
welcome to another video by simply learn
i'm sure you must have watched our
previous videos on automation anywhere
if you haven't watched them already i
suggest you to go through easy tutorials
on every topic on automation anywhere
automation anywhere is a well-known rpa
tool it has grown in popularity over the
years and is now used by organizations
all over the world
automation anywhere enables id
departments to set up software robots
that collect and interpret data in
variety of applications
if you are planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or automation
anywhere developer role
here is a comprehensive list of most
frequently asked automation anywhere
interview questions with answers
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
click
on the bell icon so you never miss an
update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
we'll first look at the beginner level
questions
what is automation anywhere automation
anywhere is well known robotic process
automation tool
that enables business to automate
end-to-end business operations
it provides powerful and user-friendly
rpa capabilities
such as cloud native web-based
intelligent automation solution
for automating any complex tasks it is a
web based management system
that employs a control room to execute
automated tasks
it improves the efficiency of business
process and reduces the need for human
labor
what are the features of automation
anywhere automation anywhere offers an
easy to use
interface for building bots and
designing business process automation
workflows
it supports multiple operating system
such as windows
linux and mac os it consists of a
recorder that works on a variety of
platforms
including microsoft windows citrix web
and sap
it consists of different bot views for
collaboration flow view for business
users
list view for developers and dual view
for collaboration
automation anywhere supports platforms
like javascript
python and vbscript as well as advanced
variable capabilities
another key feature is its versatile
architecture that allows for the
addition of new command packages
what are the different components in
automation anywhere
automation anywhere robotic interface
aari
is a user friendly interface that allows
business users to collaborate with bots
aari enables enterprises to unlock
previously unavailable automation
opportunities
between humans and bots that rpa could
not address
iqbot an intelligent document processing
solution
capable of reading and processing a wide
range of complex documents and emails
iqbod intelligently captures classifies
and extracts semi-structured and
unstructured data using rpa
and multiple ai techniques allowing
document-centric business process to be
automated end-to-end
bot insight the analytics platform that
delivers real-time
interactive and intelligent insights
into the business process and
operational intelligence
discovery bot an intelligent business
solution for enterprise business
that enables end users to discover
automation opportunities through process
discovery
discovery board collaborates with
business workers to identify automation
opportunities
that can maximize the return on your rpi
investment
what is an enterprise control room and
how does it work
the enterprise control room serves as a
single point of management for all bots
the enterprise control room manages
schedules
executes and configures various bots and
bot runner capabilities
using a collection of specialized web
services
the enterprise control room is placed on
a server in the data center
and configured to work with the other
data center components
explain the different type of bots in
automation anywhere
taskbot task boards are used for
automating repetitive tasks based on the
rules
these tasks are simple to create and can
reliably complete multi-step procedures
document administration claims
management
hr departments i.t and other areas
benefit from task bots
metabot metabots are more advanced
version of taskbots
metabots are automation building
components that help with next
generation integration scalability
these are intended for a scalable
complex process
on a computer meta bots are used to
automate applications
iqbot iqbots are the next generation of
intelligent bots
with the ability to think like humans
these bots are designed to learn on
their own
and carry out tasks in accordance with
that learning
iqbots also learn to recognize patterns
so that the bot knows exactly what to do
the next time the pattern appears with
each human confirmation
it learns and improves its ability to
carry out the act
explain briefly the architecture of
automation anywhere
automation anywhere platform is built
using a distributed architecture
the enterprise control room is a
web-based platform that manages the
development and execution of digital
workforce
and provides a centralized management
bot creators and bot runners are linked
to the enterprise control room
bot creators are software development
platforms for authorizing and
customizing automations
bot runners are runtime system deployed
on machines that carry out the
automations
bot runners can be installed on desktops
in data centers or in the cloud
what is a bot creator a bot is a
self-contained task that requires little
to no human intervention to complete
the bot creator is a customized
development client for automation
anywhere that is used to create bots
task editor event watcher bot player
auto login
and local scheduler are all included the
bot creator also includes the ability to
create bots from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application the device is registered
with the enterprise control room after
the bot creator user
signs in for the first time and the user
can deploy bots on that device
what is a bot runner a bot runner has
ability to run bots from a device
utilizing the enterprise client
application the device is registered
with the enterprise control room
after the bot runner user locks in for
the first time and the user can deploy
bots on that device
bots are run by bot runner which is a
software machine
bot runners can run bots at a scale
after they have been developed by the
bot creator
explain triggers in automation anywhere
triggers
integrate predefined events into your
process reducing the amount of tasks
that users must do repeatedly in
automation anywhere
you can use attendant automation to
create unique triggers for numerous apps
these triggers can then be used to
launch a bot
at triggers to have the bot execute
automatically whenever a specified event
occurs for
instance pressing a specific key or
series of key strokes
explain the benefits of automation
anywhere
time saving an easy to use interface
that allows users of varying skill
levels
to easily use the product and accelerate
the learning process
with instant web-based deployment you
can get started with writing bots right
away
business adaptability automation
anywhere provides regular updates
ensuring that you are always up to date
on any device anywhere
it provides continuity of operations
with high availability and disaster
recovery
low cost of ownership there is no need
for additional infrastructure investment
a unified platform for front office back
office and employee applications
it gives lower maintenance cost
what are bought insights the analytics
platform that delivers
real-time interactive and intelligent
insights into business process
and operational intelligence bot insight
takes a large amount of content level
and productivity data
generated by deployed bots and converts
it into insights via automatically
generated and customizable dashboards
what are the different excel packages
that automation anywhere offers
automation anywhere offers three
different excel packages
excel advanced package it's utilized to
automate actions involving the workbook
worksheet
rows columns and cells the system must
have microsoft office installed
the versions of microsoft office that
are supported range from
2016 to microsoft office 2019.
excel basic package enables quick
spreadsheet activities
for dot xlsx files without requiring the
msxl software to be installed
office 365 excel it provides commands
for working with
excel online the office 365 excel bundle
includes actions that allow you to
automate operations
in microsoft excel online if you are
using microsoft excel 365 via a web
browser
you can use the office 365 excel package
to automate excel process
let us look at the intermediate level
questions
explain functions of the following excel
commands
open spreadsheet allows to open the
excel spreadsheet
close spreadsheet closes a spreadsheet
that was opened
save spreadsheet saves a spreadsheet in
an open workbook
activate spreadsheet activates a
specific spreadsheet in an open workbook
it specifies whether to activate the
sheet by index
or sheet by name
get cell allows to retrieve the values
of a specific cell
as well as the range of the cell set
cell
sets the value of the active cell or a
specific cell in an excel spreadsheet
you can assign a variable to the cell
value
go to cell move to a specific cell
within a spreadsheet
delete cell delete the value of a
specific cell within a excel spreadsheet
run excel macro runs a macro that is
stored within an
excel spreadsheet enter the macro name
and specify the parameters of the macro
arguments
explain the types of triggers to start
abort
email in email trigger a bot is launched
when a new email message arrives in the
given email service
such as microsoft outlook email server
or ews file and folder
when a predefined file or folder event
occurs it starts a bot
as the trigger you can choose from the
following options
like when you make a new file or a
folder or when a file or a folder that
already exists
gets destroyed or when you rename a file
or a folder
the next type is hotkey when a
predetermined combination of keystrokes
is performed on the keyboard a bot is
launched
as the trigger you can use any
combination
like control alt windows
and escape are all control keys
particular alphabetical characters are
used in the key
interface when a predetermined event
occurs on the selected user
interface element abort is launched
some instances of pre-configured events
are a button is pressed by the user
or an application is opened or closed by
the user
a check box is selected or cleared by
the user
how to record the task with universal
recorder
step 1. create a new bot or open an
existing bot
then click on the start recording and
select universal recording
step 3 perform the required steps and
click on finish
step 4 edit the actions and click on
save
let's jump into the automation in our
control room and
see how to record the task with
universal recorder
so here we are in the control room we
have created a new bot
so let's search for a message box
double click on the message box
enter a message
close message box after 5 seconds
now go to start recording or you can
press ctrl
plus r click on start recording
and select the window which you want to
record
so i'll select the calculator
and click on universal recorder
and now you can perform actions
so i'm adding the numbers
uh
so i have randomly performed some
actions now i'll click on
finish and let's finish the recording
now let us save and click on run
so here you can see the message is
displayed hello it will close in 5
seconds and it has closed
and the recording is been played and it
shows the actions which we have recorded
you can see your bot has run
successfully
how to clone a bot in automation
anywhere
create a read-only duplicate of the bot
in the private workspace from the public
workspace
so you can have a local copy without
checking it out
step 1 log into the control room as a
bot creator user
and then in public space click bots the
my bot page is displayed with the list
of folders or files containing the bot
then select the bot you want to clone
click the actions menu
and click clone task bot the clone bot
appears in the same folder structure in
the private workspace
so let's jump into the automation in our
control room and see how to clone a bot
so this is the my bot folder so these
are the bots which i have created
so let's go to this python board select
this bot
and go to the options and
click here copy task bot
and here you can see a copy of that bot
is been created
and name the bot whatever you want so
i'll keep the default name
python board copy one and click on copy
you can select the folder where you want
to store it i have kept the default
folders
and here you can see python board copy
one has been successfully created
so that is how you clone a bot
explain the following commands delay
command weight command
and task command the delay command is
used to delay the execution of next
command
for a set length of time you have the
option of specifying the time in
milliseconds or seconds
wait command the wait command is used to
add a condition
that forces the next set of actions to
wait for the contents
of a screen to change before proceeding
task command task command is used to
start a task within a task
or pause it and stop it
explain predefined variables in
automation anywhere
predefined variables are variables that
provide specific information
about the machine on which the bot is
run
the values of a preset variable cannot
be changed by users
below are the examples of predefined
variables clipboard
date and time string and system settings
and parameters
explain the date time predefined
variables in automation anywhere
using the datetime packages activities
you can manipulate date and time
variables
date returns a date that includes the
hours minutes and seconds
day the day is written in date format
r is a function that returns the rs in
as format
machine the device name is returned as a
string by the machine
millisecond millisecond returns a value
between
0 and triple 9 milliseconds
minute the minutes are returned in
minute format
month month is a function that returns
the month
in month format seconds the seconds are
returned in seconds format
year returns the current year in the
year format
how are loops used to control a bot in
automation anywhere
loops are one of the most powerful board
building constructions
loops are the instructions that repeat a
set of actions
a certain number of times or until a
condition is met
when a loop checks for the completion of
a defined number of iterations
or satisfaction of a condition if not
satisfied
the loop is executed the same conditions
are checked repeatedly
until the condition has been satisfied
if the condition is satisfied
then the loop is not being executed
explain error handling and automation
anywhere
error handling in automation anywhere
consists of the error handler package
that comprises actions that make it
simple to handle exceptions
that abort encounters and pass control
to the bot's other activities
you can use the error handler actions to
separate the actions that you can't use
to complete a
task from the actions or to handle an
exception
when a bot meets an error handling
exceptions ensure that the work is
complete
how is automation anywhere different
from uipath
on the basis of single integrated
automation platform
automation anywhere provides intelligent
automation platform like
attended automation unattended
automation intelligent document
processing and many more
whereas uipath requires third party
products and integration to deliver a
similar solution
increasing installation and support
complexity
modern architecture automation anywhere
provides efficient java based micro
service architecture
ensuring scalability reducing the cost
of infrastructure and maintenance
ui path on the other hand built on a
legacy window
workflow foundation with the last update
released in 2012
the scalability is slow and difficult
due to lack of modularity
ease of use in automation anywhere the
easy
use platform enables regular employees
to create their own automation
but uipath is targeted towards the
developer community
and needs more intervention from it and
development team
most secure and compliant automation
anywhere
provides the best in-class security
standard whereas uipath
has incomplete security certifications
that create business
and compliance risk easier to scale
automation anywhere quickly scales to
thousands of bots in front and back
office
no matter the type attended unattended
or document processing
ui paths architecture unable to scale
horizontally
and required to duplication of entire
application for every service expansion
quicker roi in automation anywhere
the modern microservices architecture
enables a platform to scale both
vertically and horizontally
delivering faster roi in ui path
with most deployments limited to a
single digit large scale deployments
become difficult
explain javascript package in automation
anywhere
the javascript package contains actions
that allow a bot to run javascript
on windows linux and unix-based devices
these activities can launch javascript
the javascript includes the following
actions open
this action opens a javascript file in
automation anywhere
close this action closes the session and
specifies the same session name from the
open action
run javascript action runs a function
within the java script
now let us look at some of the advanced
level automation anywhere interview
questions
how to write inline scripts using python
command in automation anywhere
step 1 create a new bot and step 2
drag and drop the following actions that
is python script
open execute function and python script
close
finally add a message box to display the
result variable let us go to the
automation in our control room
so i have already created a bot
i'll open that bot
search for the python script package
from the python script package drag and
drop the open function
in the open function specify the session
name if you already have an existing
file on your device
then select the import existing device
and enter the file path
or you can enter the input manually so i
have entered the input manually in which
i have defined a function
function which i have named it as name
and i have called an
argument called string and i have
returned that argument
so select the python runtime version in
my device python version 3 is installed
so i have selected the three
and then drag and drop the python script
in this enter the session name and enter
the name of function to be executed
as you can see here in the previous open
action
i have entered the function name as name
so and enter this in the python script
action enter the
name of the function then argument to
the function
create a variable so i have created a
variable and named it as
python variable so and i have assigned
the value to this variable
and i have assigned a value called
thanks to this variable
and then in the display message enter
the
variable which you had created so we had
created
the variable python variable and
assigned it
so enter the variable just second
so select the variable and then close
the message box after 10 seconds
then once you open the python script
then we have to close the python script
as well
and the session name should be the same
so for in detail explanation and better
understanding check out
our tutorial on automation anywhere
using python
check out this video in which i have
explained all the steps in detail
how python is used in automation anyway
so now
we'll click on save and click on save
and run this
downloading dependencies downloading
dependencies
and here you go the message from the bot
is being displayed as
thanks this was the value which we had
assigned to the variable
and the window will close in 10 seconds
how to create a credential in automation
anywhere
step 1 navigate to bots and go to the
credentials section
then enter the credential name and
description for the configured
credential
then enter the attribute name and supply
the description for the attribute
then select the external keyword then
select input
standard or user provided set the
security
and click create credential let's go to
the automation anywhere and create a
credential
in the control room go to manage
in the manage you can see credentials
click on credentials
and if you if you go here you can see
create credential
click on create credential enter the
credential name
enter the credential description which
is optional
then scroll down and enter the attribute
name
whatever the attribute you want enter
the attribute name and enter the
description which is optional
and provide the input either you can
keep the input standard or user provided
when you keep the input as user provided
when the credential is added to the
locker
an email will be sent to the consumer of
the locker so you will receive an email
but we don't want to receive an email so
we'll keep it as standard
and enter the value so enter
the value of the attribute which you are
creating and you can keep the value it
must
when you keep it masked the value gets
encrypted usually we use it for
passwords when you enter the password
we encrypt the value that is why we
select mask
and you can create the attribute like
this and if you want you can
create multiple attributes click on plus
and you can create the multiple
attributes
once you have created the attributes
then when you scroll up here you can see
this option create credential
this option will get enabled then you
click on create credential and the
credential gets created
this is how you create a credential
how to set up a locker and assign
credentials
step 1 create and assign rules step 2
create a credential
and step 3 create a locker so it is very
simple
let's go to the control room
go to the credentials sections in this
you can see the lockers option here
go to lockers and click on create locker
once you click on create locker enter
the locker name enter the description
so in the credentials whatever
credentials you have created will be
shown here
so i have already deposited this
credential in the locker that is why it
is
disabled for me so once you have created
the credential
check this box select the credential and
click here to deposit this credential in
the
locker once that is done go to the
owners
and select the owner
so your owner email address will be
shown here
select that email address and deposit
that in the locker
once that is done go to managers this is
optional
and this manager is not enabled in the
community edition
and even the participants this is also
not enabled in the community edition
so skip these two steps and go to
consumers and in consumers
check the community edition user and
deposit that in the locker
once this much is done you can see this
option create locker this option will
get
enabled so click on create locker
and the blocker will get created check
out my previous video on
automation anywhere excel operations in
which i have shown how to create a
credential and how to create a locker in
detail
create a bot to login web page using
automation anywhere
actions using the above question are as
follows we will use the browser package
that contains actions
that enable you to download files fight
broken lines and launch a website
it contains a capture action from the
recorder package to capture an
interaction with the user interface
object
such as text box button table etc
let's go to the automation in your
control room and create a bot to login
web page using automation anywhere
so this is the login bot which i have
already created
you can check out our automation
anywhere tutorial in which i have
detailedly explained each step
how to create a bot to login inside any
web page
so basically in this we are using a
browser action
in the browser action we will open it in
the new window
will browse in the google chrome you can
select whichever you want
for now i have selected google chrome
and select the link to open
so in this project i will login inside
the simply learns webpage
so for that i have selected the link
that is the
link in the simply lens so go to the
simply lens web page go to the login
page
and i have copied this link of the login
page
so i have pasted the link to open here
then i have used the recorder package
from the recorder package i have used
the capture action in which
in the first action i'll capture the
email address in the second
capture action i'll capture the password
in the third capture action i'll click
on the login button
so i have captured this three action so
let us
save and click on run
here you go it has opened the webpage in
the new window
so entering the email address password
and clicking on the login button
and it has logged it inside the simply
learns webpage
and your bot has run successfully
create a bot to merge two data tables
from a different excel sheets into a new
sheet
so to merge two data tables together in
a single data table
in automation anywhere we use merge
action from the data table package
so let's go to automation anywhere so i
have the two excel files file one and
file two so
in file one i have six rows
of employee names and salaries
in file two i have five rows of salary
of salaries and employee names so i'll
merge both these tables
into a new excel sheet so for that
let us go to let us go to the automation
anywhere control room
you can check out our automations
anywhere excel operations videos
in which we have explained all the excel
operations and actions in detail
in step one i have selected the file one
that is i have opened the excel file one
and assigned it to get multiple cell
actions
and close the file similarly in step 2 i
have opened the file to
and similarly assign the get multiple
cells and
close the file tool then from the data
table package
from the data table package i have used
this merged
action this merges two data tables
together in a single data table
so i have used this so i have used this
action
so i'll disable the
other actions click on save and run the
file
so the excel bot is running and a new
file
name named as result will be created on
the desktop
so the bot has run successfully let us
go to the desktop
and see the result file which got
created let us open this file
and here you can see both the data
tables have been merged
into a new excel files six first six
rows from the file one and the next five
rows from the file tool
have been merged into a single data
table
how to remove duplicate rows from a data
table in automation anywhere
to remove duplicate rows from the data
table use remove duplicate rows action
from the data table package
as you can see in this data table there
is a duplicate row named john
which is repeated twice
so let us go to automation anywhere and
perform
action to remove this duplicate rows so
let us close this
so if you go to the data table action
here you can see remove duplicate rows
so double click on this and then you
will get the do
double click on remove duplicate rows
and in do remove duplicate rows select
the
data table name so i'm selecting the
data variable which i had created
so just specify the data table name and
the automation anywhere will remove the
duplicate rows
so let us click on save and
let us run
here you can see the excel bot is
running it is opening both the excel
files it is checking for duplicate rows
and your bot has successfully run
so let us close this and go to desktop
and here you can see the duplicate row
has been deleted
so there was one more duplicate row with
the name john
so that row has been deleted so this is
how you delete duplicate rows in
automation
from the excel from the data table the
last question
how to sort data in the data table using
automation anywhere
to sort data in a data table automation
anywhere provides a sort action from the
data table package
so if you look at this data table you
can see the salaries column
the salaries is not sorted so we'll sort
the salary scholar
in the descending order the employee
with the highest salary
will be at the top and the employee with
the lowest salary will be at the bottom
so let's close this
and we'll enable this sort data action
so
what you have to do is select sort data
action from the data table package
once you select this specify the data
table name
and the column name so we want to sort
the column salaries
then select the order in which you want
to sort will sort
it in the descending order click on save
and click on run
here you can see deploying to the
computer downloading the dependencies
and the bot is running
so your bot has run successfully let's
go to desktop
and open the file results
and here you can see the data is sorted
in the descending order
the employee with the highest salary is
at the top
similarly in the decreasing order the
employee with the lowest salary
is at debauchery so with that we have
reached the end of this video
like and share it if you found it
interesting and thank you for being here
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
love
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here